hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's you guys were practically
begging me to play this again and I'm
glad you agree that this is probably one
of the scariest games I have ever played
the mechanics are so incredibly unique I
love everything about it and at the same
time I absolutely hate it because I have
to play it now I do objective in this
particular episode is I'm gonna try to
meet the whole game I don't want to
waste your guys's time I'm gonna try to
get as far as I can or if I rage quit
like a little baby that's gonna happen
to who you
yeah he's out already
hi you get close real quick right yeah
yeah
there are blind spots on camera right
outside yes I won on your cameras be
sure to check the door yeah about a fine
Wow
he's still there I could see a shadow
also a pirate where's the guy I don't
know anyone here I'm sure you wait a
minute cross the money off easy she's
still there hands in there
whoa what is that what the hell is that
what happened no no no no you can't tell
me nothing happened well that'll happen
there is he still there you know when he
go screw himself I can't deal with this
you're gonna make me keep that door
locked
he's just gotta stand there he's gonna
stand there like a creepy gonna use up
all my power
aw crap this is not good well this got
off to a pleasant start didn't I thought
I was might maybe gonna skid right by
Meg - and I wasn't be gonna be able to
get to the rest of the game but this guy
he's not leaving why is he not leaving
oh god I'm never gonna make it because
still fair go away
nobody likes you
it's out there why why is he still there
what do we do
Oh what do we do what do I do whatever
do iams I'm dead I'm screwed
I'm so very screwed he's not leaving
he's gonna suck up all my power I'm
gonna be dead you son of a [ __ ] I hate
you
why the music mr. ducky still over there
so he said something good but God I
can't even go on the camera now because
it sucks up power everything you do even
looking at the camera takes power you
guys help me figure that out and god
damn would you just get okay alright
okay now that we're calming down just a
little bit maybe you could give me a
breather and stop hanging around my door
where'd you go where are you guys let's
see what are you where's the other no no
no not not okay no no talk he just likes
to stare in the Camry he does see oh oh
hi there you are okay whole via our
insight you're doing good just need to
stay there Oh change again I hear that
hear that let's go where'd you go huh no
Bogart no there's one where's the other
god damn this game just freaks me the F
out I'm sorry if i spects that Allah by
spastically switch cameras because this
is not okay is one of them in the
kitchen is that what that sound is room
that doesn't have a light in it
fire coma oh you're closed you need to
settle the F down because I do not have
enough power to make it through the rest
of the night now you're such a son of a
[ __ ] there anymore
good stay away God you [ __ ] it's
only night too
I'm gonna try to beat this game hi
friend
you're looking good we just say you're
the pretty oh he's gone
would you go where'd you go where'd you
go we go
why I can't waste any power
escape I'm a baby I'm a big baby
oh my why did I get this crap job I
could have gotten more money washing
dishes somewhere huh huh that's why
YouTube cuz I can't live in the real
world
where's the duck she wears a decade at
least pirate Cove man is still nice and
son of a [ __ ] with a creepy ass eyes
can you not had that door closed like
the whole game cylinder Oh can't deal
can deal can deal my friend are you
doing you look good
gone yet nope still there cuz what would
it be a party without my good friend mr.
bun bun and mr. happy duck mr. quacky
smack Oh what am I supposed to do
alright cool man still good I don't know
I was playing the demo version before
and now but he's gone
I'm not gonna make it I got two hours
left in 14% power and literally not
gonna make it I'm dead I'm dead this
whole thing is for naught
I'm dead I was playing the demo
beforehand I bought the full game it is
available the full game is available cuz
I almost made the mistake of playing the
demo again and that ends on night two
actually really wanting to try to beat
this game and I don't want to disappoint
you guys
ty professional hi welcome to the party
friend oh please tell me that you're not
gonna kill they'd really rather not
I know I know Oh
I don't have enough power I'm gonna
diamond a diamond today 5% are you
kidding me gonna last another hour on 4%
please leave
I can't even risk looking at the camera
now good thanks
no 2% Oh 2% milk
oh well presenting I hate it good we're
gonna go to skin
we're gonna go skin levels of power I'm
so dead oh no no no no no no no hold out
just a little longer turn turn turn turn
it turns at six
my microphone and our my microphone over
oh oh oh I think I heard something okay
ow
fast Cree was so bad it hurt my voice so
I'm gonna try to take this next one
really easy in order to save time I
might skip ahead a few times but you
won't miss out on any of the action okay
okay okay this is good this is fine it's
good it's good I like this I like this
mr. duckies on the move ah there's mr.
ducky mr barbour Freddie wants to be
friendly I'm like a wild animal when I
get cornered I'll punch you straight in
the Gabba swear on me mum
friend me Mom everybody but being a
little nice being a little nicer I gotta
admit look good guys that's not a good
guy
but the good guys I like him I like him
a lot
laughter you
mr. ducky still staying away he's a
smart one
I just gotta listen listening is
important listening is very key in this
game because you can save power by
hearing them checking very periodically
cuz they could jump like from across the
frickin building right to you so it
doesn't even matter none of that none of
that No
good to go where to go where to go where
to go Ducky's moved cookie boy what is
that can't handle this cannot won't dad
don't bond share that I have is just
about enough of you
yeah
damn Indian tape our nitrogen stopped
making soda sounds around me as I cool
where are they where the hell are they
okay there he is no someone's in the
kitchen
no some of these kitchen are go man
still okay not come out of a shadow this
another size
oh god the changing oh god they're
changing no no no no it's really bad
that I can't see doc man no no no no no
don't you know that I don't care who it
is okay who Freddie you gonna help your
hell you yeah okay it's fun man went
away okay cool just lay off I'm gonna
make it
I got enough power I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna make it in the kitchen again he's
in the kitchen and god it's such a
psychological thing I'm just standing
here doing nothing I'm just standing
here I'm literally just standing here
there's nothing I could do but wait for
them to come to me this leg throws off
everything I knew about war we go hi
getting closer because it used to be
that the scariest thing was making me do
something I didn't want to do by
actually make me do something but now
I'm literally just sitting here doing
nothing but waiting for them to try to
kill me so goddamn paranoid prick still
good I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make
through night - what are you doing
you're still there okay that's not fun
hi are you doing no apples are you still
there still there oh god damn a white
you got doing this to me
why are you bucking you're gone you're
gone okay you're gone you're gone
yeah don't you dum-dum to nobody you
don't dumb down to do you know the only
thing I really got a check it's Pirates
Cove as far as I know the rules for now
got a dumb dumb dumb knowledge I don't
like you we designed this place Satan I
don't even got it it's really I don't I
don't really have to check where they
are
except for Pirates Cove just have to
keep an eye on it the other than that
I'm good like as far as I know the game
right now but we made it past night -
now the other night for them to change
up the rules on me I'll appreciate that
I don't I don't appreciate that
so come on bring it on what do you got
for me okay nine three here we go I'm
ready call me up buddy thank you there
you are how's it going
yes hello I'm ready Oh
most people don't last this long you
know
things but yeah Oh
gorzan who would much of your time
let's start getting a we had an idea
if you want to get caught and what to
avoid getting stuffed into a Freddy King
try playing dead you know
Oh God what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] okay
not okay who's this listen to a nice
conversation you know you cannot choose
rules oh my god oh my god that's a cool
I worry about with them what the hell is
that Freddy Freddy voodoo Freddy do bone
Freddy don't Frick with me try to go to
hell
what the hell was that I need to go in
post I need to freeze frame on what the
hell that was because I have no goddamn
idea I swear no game has ever made me
this jumpy I'm freaking paranoid
every goddamn little moyson I don't know
what's got throw me next Scott surprise
me [ __ ] hi okay you're getting closer
but you're not quite here mr. ducky
you're getting a little close for me I'm
sorry if I don't have anything
interesting to say right now I'm
actually very focused on what I'm doing
right now and I don't want many
distractions god I actually feel oh hi
there you actually feel this strange
need to survive only now if I feel
actually in danger too if I if I screw
this up
oh yeah it's like this something
actually at stake here
Oh like it I'm very [ __ ] right now
and I apologize if this is disorienting
for people cuz I know you probably can't
see my mouse and also you don't know
where I'm about to click before I do but
okay now nothing's happening no no no no
okay are you just messing around the
kitchen cuz that's fine if you just want
to get up for a midnight snack I'm a
security guard but all allowed cold
still good one bun hasn't come out of
climb
ducky ducky ducky Turkey turkey Turkey
turkey Turkey turkey quick cuppa tea
ducky go away kikiki no one loves you I
think the duck am i a might just be that
the duck can only appear on the right
wait was that good um number what is
Swift that what is with the do dahm dahm
I don't even know anymore I know I'd
really tell him to know I don't
understand this game and I'm not even
gonna try to do that
it's gotta make it through the night
Nowell Oh God like white why who who's
there no one okay god damn it you're
already out I'm sorry I didn't
Oh pissing balls would I even have fast
enough reflexes to stop him
Oh Zanna sir bun bun coming out of his
hidey-hole got in so freakin fast right
now
I think mr. bonbon came out of his
hidey-hole no he did not
why is he not nothing's actually
happening tonight besides that weird
experience with the whatever the hell
teddy bear was on the floor bleeding oh
god they're all out oh god they're all
out oh my god when did they all get out
oh my god where are they oh my god with
Smita harbor oh no no no no no no no no
no no that was that oh crap
Oh F me oh they're all out where are
they oh they're all out No
oh they are all out they are all out
Fran where the frico Frank are they okay
ones down that hallway I don't know
where Trey turns out I don't know even
know no one's down that hallway
where are the other two the other two
are unaccounted for there's one there's
two no not her anymore Christmas okay
there's one ha ha
once there's one oh god a cage no no no
who's that
stop that oh my god you stop that right
now
oh he's close he's right outside the
door he's either coming this way oh god
he's here
oh yes I knew it I knew your number I
had it I knew you were coming keep still
there someone's in the kitchen
I don't know I was console just pointing
at the screen how's this considerably
pointy of the screen a guy on a power I
could make it
hearts go still okay check check the one
to week still there that's okay I got
enough power I can make it ducky over
there honey where's the bad bears
nowhere to be found there's no order to
be mine
alright Cove Doka Doka 5:00 a.m. I can
make it I can make it even with that
door closed you stay there all you want
I'll get back it may give you sassafras
you son of a [ __ ] shove it up your ass
no no what do they do that for the wrong
button all right oh god I can make it I
can keep these doors closed for as long
as I need to
are you gone yeah that's right I got it
I got it on lock discuss my voice is
cracking a little bit doesn't mean that
you've affected me okay I got it
I got this ain't got nothing on me I can
keep these door closed
I'm the winner I'm a winner baby I'm a
winner I'm a winner baby I'm a winner
baby no no that's not okay I got you
you're both here good wouldn't be a
party without the both of you but I'm
gonna ride this out until the end of the
night go screw yourself you can say
they're all god no oh my god if the
power goes out and they're there
will I die no no no no come on please no
Hey oh cool all right okay okay all
right okay all right okay all right I'm
gonna try the fourth night if I can't
make it I'll pick it up in another
episode but I promise I'm gonna really
try to beat this okay hello
hello yes please
oh wow day four you can do it hey listen
I may not be around to sit
but a bad guy here
my messages for you
I did
checks if you want me so bad
ah
Oh onion check pirate Cove enough I was
worried about what that guy was go
through how can you be there so early oh
okay alright I'll pick this up in
another one
Oh God Oh get detective a piece of my
lung oh my god this is go Guerra there's
a cookie this is a good game
so anyway okay this is probably this is
probably I say this sometimes but this
is probably the scariest game I've ever
played I've never felt such paranoia and
it says it's not even a sense of dread
anymore it's just I know I'm gonna die
and I don't know when it's gonna happen
that's the kind of feeling I got oh my
god Oh
alright so anyway that's all I got for
this episode I'm really gonna try to be
doing the next one thank you all so much
for watching and believing in me and let
me know what to do in the next one if
there's any advice you got I don't think
there's any advice to give but thank you
all so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye